a
en colombia mueren 6 líderes sociales
cada semana 600 habrían muerto desde
2016 entre estas víctimas se encuentran
líderes ambientales que suelen vivir en
zonas geográficamente estratégicas y con
riqueza en recursos naturales de hecho
colombia es el país del mundo más
peligroso para un líder ambiental según
la ong británica global witness en 2019
fueron 64 los asesinados algo que no ha
cesado en 2020 como demuestra el
asesinato a finales de octubre de la
hispano colombiana juana maría perea que
se oponía a la construcción de un puerto
en el paradisiaco tribugá en el pacífico
del país para evitar estas matanzas en
diciembre de 2019 el presidente de
colombia iván duque firmó el acuerdo de
escazú un acuerdo medioambiental para
américa latina que otorgará mayor
protección a las comunidades ya los
ecosistemas en colombia todavía falta
que el congreso lo ratifique mientras
las perspectivas para 2021 son
preocupantes en pleno año preelectoral
con economías ilegales disparadas como
la pasta de coca y el precio del oro y
además el año en el que salgan las
primeras medidas de la justicia
transicional
[Música]
lugar en el ranking mundial de
asesinatos de líderes medioambientales y
se queda solo por detrás de filipinas y
de colombia los datos son de la ong
internacional global witness y se
refieren al año 2019 cuando fueron
contabilizados por lo menos 24
asesinatos el 90% de sus crímenes son
perpetrados en la amazonía brasileña de
hecho en 2019 el crimen más sonado fue
el asesinato del líder
paulinho wesson sahara que luchaba
contra las invasiones de tierras
indígenas en el estado de maranháo este
informe es realizado desde 2012 y
muestra que américa latina es el peor
lugar del mundo para los activistas que
defienden la tierra y la naturaleza y
muchas de las personas que trabajan en
la amazonía brasileña reconocen que la
situación ha empeorado desde la llegada
al gobierno de jair bolsonaro porque
todas las personas que cometen ilícitos
buscadores de oro madereros invasores de
tierra se sienten legitimados por su
discurso
[Música]
de acuerdo con el centro mexicano de
derecho ambiental entre 2012 y 2017
hubo 83 homicidios de activistas y no
sólo eso sino que en ese periodo se
tiene también el reporte de 500 ataques
contra defensores del medio ambiente tan
solo en febrero de 2019
hubo 15 personas asesinadas y uno de los
casos más emblemáticos es el de samir
flores una activista indígena que se
oponía a una central termoeléctrica en
el estado de morelos el crimen ocurrió
en febrero de 2019 ya la fecha sigue
impune y continúan las protestas
oaxaca es el estado de la república con
mayor cantidad de agresiones a
defensores del medio ambiente y de
acuerdo con la organización frontline
defenders méxico es junto a brasil el
cuarto país más peligroso para los
activistas
[Música]